what's up everybody
movie retrospective time doing an old
black and white classic
yeah but it was color well no it's not
really but
well here's the situation with this okay
so this is carnival of souls from 1962.
and obviously this movie was shot in
black and white and that's
how i've seen it like most times like
i've seen this movie probably like 20
times
and the actually the black and white
cinematography is uh quite beautiful
um you know especially considering how
inexpensive this movie was to make
however i thought tom had already seen
it and i was like well i've seen it a
bunch of times
so let's watch one of the riff tracks
versions because they actually did
a regular version they did a live
version and i also have a version on dvd
that's just mike from uh you know from
msd slash rifftrax
doing a commentary on it and that's also
the colorized version
i don't love the colorize brush they did
a good job
colorizing it but honestly if you're
gonna watch this and you're not gonna
like
you know have fun with it like rifftrax
did which is kind of what i was in the
mood for
um i would definitely recommend just
watching the regular
black and white version because i think
that when they colorize it i think it
loses a lot of the atmosphere
that it has but or you know that it
originally had
but um i saw that very recently they had
just released
um a criterion collection one that's all
been remastered and it's 4k and
everything and that's supposed to look
like
you know dynamite so i just i haven't
seen that version
this movie is another one where like
night of the living dead
it sort of accidentally got into the
public domain
because of like some paperwork errors or
some [ __ ] like that so at least in the
united states it's public domain like
not in other countries i think they
sorted it out which means everything's a
bootleg
yeah so so that's why you kind of see
this movie everywhere like you can watch
it for free on tubey you can watch it's
on shutter it's on
you know it's everywhere and that's why
because it's like really cheap and
that's why i probably rip tracks have
done it like three or four times at this
point just because it's like you don't
have to pay anybody
so as i said this came out in 1962. now
this was made
by a dude named herc harvey
who also plays the main ghoul in this
like the guy that's pursuing the main
character
he actually worked for centron
and if any of you guys and i know
because i know some of you guys are like
mystery science theater fans
centron was probably one of the largest
producers of those kind of like short
films like educational films industrial
you know why study industrial arts and
all that kind of stuff um
so they did all of those and that's what
her carvey was mainly doing he was
shooting those he also taught filmmaking
and things like that as well
um so he was just like shooting you know
short educational films
and i guess the the impetus for him
making a feature film
was actually the site uh you know the
abandoned carnival
which i think is actually that's in utah
where and they say that in the movie
that that's where it is
and it's on the great salt lake like
it's a place called saltaire or
something
and uh so he liked the look of that so
much
that he basically approached a dude like
a screenwriting dude he knew
and he said okay well like one of the
last scenes has to be like a bunch of
ghouls like dancing around in this
abandoned you know carnival but up to
that like just figure something out
like just so so this was kind of one of
those
one of those cases and i kind of say
this if you don't have a lot of money to
make a movie
like find a really good setting and like
write a movie around that and that's
essentially what this dude did
yeah it's been said over and over again
to do that escape from new york was that
yeah i mean that that's what i mean and
and the thing about it so
so the guy this movie back in the day
i think it cost 33 000 to make which
even back then was
amazingly cheap i think that's kind of
like 200 grand 250 grand in today's
money
which again even today that's very very
cheap yeah if you have to pay people
yeah and that well that's the thing and
the crew i believe the crew was only
five people
and like i said the director also
starred in the movie like as the as the
ghoul
and uh candace hilagos who was the main
character
she had been a theater actress and i
think she was only in maybe two other
movies subsequently because like i said
most these were mostly like theater
people
yeah she's the main attraction to this
movie
yeah she kind of looks like that woman
from species she's pretty good-looking
she is she was only 20 when she made
this other than that i think that you
know go ahead
other than that this movie i think it's
unwatchable you think yeah it's
unwatchable well like i said it's kind
of hard to see a rich
rip track rifftrax made it [ __ ] very
bearable it was funny the thing about
this movie
is that you well you have to kind of be
in the right mood to watch it because a
lot of it
is it's all kind of atmosphere
but the thing about this movie that why
people bring it up why it's such a
classic
why criterion uh wanted to do a you know
a restore on it
is that it was really really influential
and i'm not really sure
i mean i don't think he was setting out
to make like an influential movie
i think it was like a combination of
this kind of surreal type of story that
he did which was a little bit ahead of
its time
and the fact that the budget was so low
and that some of the so
some of the things in it like the acting
is very strange
and like kind of like some of the people
weren't actors
and so and some of the editing was kind
of strange so i think that
the juxtaposition of those two things
kind of hit this sort of weird sweet
spot
where because i think even like
filmmakers like you know george romero
crown and bird david lynch um you know
maybe roman polanski because this has a
little bit of a repulsion vibe to it too
um you know what i mean which you know
like i said came out after this
so i feel like this inspired even though
it's not
i don't know if you'd call it like an
objectively good movie
but there's something about it and
honestly i've watched like a [ __ ] ton of
reviews of this and some of the like uh
you know horror channels and stuff and
some of the guys are like young
like in their 20s or whatever and
there's like there's just something
about this one that just kind of like
there there's just like an atmosphere
about this one that's like really really
creepy and like unsettling you know
as i was watching it it reminded me of a
very early cronenberg
yeah kind like you know before
cronenberg really had any money it
reminded me of something like that
although cronenberg was taking it to
another level well yeah but
it wouldn't surprise me if cronenberg
had seen this movie
i think a lot of people saw this movie
because i feel like when it came out in
1962
um as i said they kind of [ __ ] up the
the copyright and so they didn't really
get
you know so it went into the public
domain really quickly
i think it was released like just as you
know the as
part of a double bill which is something
they did a lot back then like for
driving theaters and [ __ ]
uh the other movie that was released
alongside was the devil's messenger
so people like went to see it but no one
was really talking about it it didn't
really make any big splash it seemed
like
later on you know i guess through it
getting shown on tv
because it was free to show and things
like that that it started getting like
more of a cult following
and so i think that a lot of people that
were into filmmaking
just through word of mouth uh ended up
seeing this movie and finding something
in it that was like inspirational to
them you know what i'm saying i think
the inspiration was is that they saw
that thing and they said boy for short
money you can make a movie
[Laughter]
it's probably all well that's kind of
like the same like i said it's kind of
the same spirit that's
you know spurred the whole punk movement
and everything like that it's like you
know if they can do what i can do it too
um i definitely think george romero was
uh
was influenced by the big time i gotta
say night of the living dead this
[ __ ] just
light years ahead of this it is but like
i said you can see
where this comes yeah i can't i can't
yeah and i mean the thing about
knight of the living dead is that one he
had like a larger crew he didn't have
this it wasn't
it honestly didn't cost that much i
think it maybe cost twice as much to
make as this if i'm remembering
correctly
but you know what you could almost kind
of say things for manos manos was kind
of like that too
that dude had nothing he was working
with nothing
and he made it kind of a watchable
entertaining footage well i kind of
think this is
this movie is not nearly as bad as manos
oh man
but um but for some reason that man has
worked
but yeah but they're in and i think that
that's kind of what
filmmakers like george romero and people
like that were responding to they saw
that and go i can do that i can do
better
it's yeah that too but it's also kind of
like like i said it's this weird
mix of kind of like an inspired idea
and then sort of like these budgetary
limitations and like
just the way it's shot like almost kind
of makes
the the juxtaposition almost makes it
like more surreal
you know what i'm saying although in the
case of manos it was by accident
yeah but i think it was kind of by
accident in this one too yeah
i don't think that he's set out because
like i said the guy he was a he was a
competent filmmaker he made
you know short films so he knew how to
edit he knew how to do all that kind of
stuff
but um and like i said he taught
filmmaking as well but
i don't know if he taught it before if
he taught it later but he worked for
centron for a really long time and
actually he took a
three-week vacation from his job at
centron to make this movie
so they made it in three weeks they made
it in i think the first part
uh you know when she before she leaves
for utah they made it in
uh kansas lawrenceville i think it was
lawrenceville
kansas and then they shot the rest of it
in utah because like i said he found
that
carnival like that abandoned carnival
and he just thought it looked so great
and
so they should put it into a movie so
the story of this if you don't know and
like i said we're going to spoil it so
it's 1962. come on get with the program
and like i said it's [ __ ] free so
yeah and
and i'm just going to go ahead and say
if you're going to watch this watch the
rifftrax colorized version
although like i said if you're seeing it
well i just wanted to watch the rifftrax
version because i've seen the original
so many times and i was just kind of
like oh well i'll watch but
i don't i wouldn't recommend if you're
not going to watch the rift tracks i
wouldn't recommend watching the
colorized version because it doesn't
look that good i think the black and
white cinematography is much nicer
and i think that it adds a lot more to
that like the atmosphere of it to me
it's like way creepier in black and
white like when you colorize stuff it
doesn't it never looks quite right to me
that's that's jenny's advice me without
that commentary i don't think i've been
able to get through this i think i've
fallen asleep
it just i didn't i didn't like it that
much although i liked it i liked the
riff tracks version of it
i was laughing the wrist tracks version
doesn't matter
there's still like i said there's more
than one yeah so i don't know
it depends on your on your movie tastes
it it
has nowhere near as good as the night of
living dead well no well like i said
this one it's almost kind of like
and honestly not even kind of like it's
supposed to be
dreamlike because essentially
that's kind of what it is i mean it's
kind of left ambiguous but
so like i said we're gonna spoil it
because i feel like everybody has seen
this or at least
you know is familiar with the story the
the the artistic elements to the tone of
this movie like she's talking about i'm
going to say it's kind of like
it's kind of like manos hands of fate
yeah but it does have that vibe to it
and
well yeah i don't think i don't think he
did it on purpose it's not some kind of
an artistic
statement it was they were working
within the limitations of what they had
yeah and yeah it is kind of creepy but
it depends uh
it's your mileage may vary depending on
what what you're into
i mean if you're i don't know you said
some young guys watched it and liked it
maybe because they're just so alien to
them you know
it's one of those just the whole tone of
it is just very very strange
and like i said i don't think that that
was intentional
no i think that that was just kind of
like a happy meeting
of like this sort of weird surreal type
of story
which you know it is kind of like a
surreal story and
the limitations of their budget and like
what you know what they were working
within
i wasn't when i was watching it i wasn't
really expecting anything it was kind of
plotting and going a little bit
slow for me not it the things that did
happen i kind of saw them coming
it you're it's like i said your mileage
may vary it wasn't really for me
now with with the with the uh with the
what do you call it
the rifftrax version i can recommend
that i was i was appreciating
you get to see the movie and then you
get to see somebody riffing on the movie
and i just thought that was a good
experience and actually i will say if
you want to watch the
if you've seen the original so many
times like i have and um
the the rifftrax versions there there's
a regular rifftrax version and a live
rooftrax version and they are both on 2b
for free
i'm not sure if the one i think the one
with just mike the commentary with just
mike nelson
i think that's on there for free too i
have it on dvd but i'm pretty sure you
can watch all three of those versions as
well as the original version all of
those you can watch on toby
so you can have an all-day [ __ ]
marathon if you want to yeah so i guess
what jenny and i are trying to say that
is it
if you're like a serious student to film
or connoisseur you'd see the original
but if i think if you're just a regular
pedestrian person i would just i'd
probably just go for the wiftrax one
yeah i mean well like i said it depends
on how into film you are how into
you know how how patient you are with
like 60s movies
how how much are you into like
surrealism how much are you
into movies that are almost all
atmosphere because that's what this is
like i said i can more than anything i
kind of feel this may be a weird thing
to say
but i can really really see like david
lynch
uh was really kind of inspired by this
movie because a lot of his [ __ ] has the
same
has the same kind of like yeah weird
blocky kind of chunks just
weird kind of dialogue now he does it on
purpose yeah um
this one i don't think it was
necessarily done on purpose i just think
some of the
i mean like i said candace hilagos she
was only 20 at the time that she was in
this
but she had been like a stage actress so
some of these people were
actors but a lot of them were not um and
that's pretty apparent like if you watch
the movie
but in a way that kind of like lends to
this really weird just like
unmoored from reality kind of vibe yeah
everybody feels and seems very
uncomfortable
including you as as watching it it's
very
chunky unrealistic blocky dialogue the
delivery is kind of deadpan
or just weird altered because of bad
acting but it
it looks like it's done on purpose it
isn't though it's done by accident well
like i said david lynch does this [ __ ]
yeah he doesn't
do it right it does kind of take it kind
of puts you into a weird kind of
yeah you're like
and i think that's what a lot of people
are responding that's what they're
trying to say yeah
so so thanos did that same kind of thing
but yeah very good different
not on purpose yeah the thing with
madhouse is is that they couldn't ever
film anybody talking
yeah because all everything didn't
happen they didn't have sound all the
sound was added now some of the sound is
added in this later you can tell a lot
of it's over dubbed
and that was weird too like on the
bridge yeah interestingly it's weird
because like it seems like at the
beginning of this
movie there was a lot of like over
dubbing yeah and but then later
it's they had sync sound and it was fine
and he knew how to do that
so i feel like maybe what happened is
when he was shooting the original scenes
maybe something [ __ ] up that maybe
they didn't get
uh the audio and they had to go back and
they wind was getting them outside
maybe that's what it was because later
on they had it was perfectly fine
like they you know they they did
everything just fine but so
okay so yeah so the story of this
candace hilagosh who plays this woman
named mary henry now you don't know
anything about her life
prior uh to any of this really she
doesn't go much into it
the movie starts very abruptly uh it's
basically just kind of
her and two other girls yeah when it
started
yeah that's how it starts yeah it's
weird so it's two and her
you know two of her girlfriends in a car
and then there's another car
with a couple of douchey dudes in there
and they're just like hey challenging
them to a drag race
and the girl that's driving who was
never named or anything
and they're just like okay that sounds
like a good idea so i'm like the world's
slowest drag race
and then so they're on this bridge uh
which is in kansas
and uh you know essentially the dudes
well
i mean it kind of looks like the boys
car is supposed to like run them off the
bridge
they actually did fun fact they did
actually wreck that bridge
um because the townspeople they were
like hey can we drive a car off the
bridge and the t
and the town you know whoever mayor or
whatever he was like uh yeah as long as
you pay to fix it you know how much it
cost to fix it twelve dollars
so they drove a [ __ ] car so uh so the
girls car goes off the bridge yeah it's
real too
uh yeah so yeah they don't have special
effects so they're like well
you got it there goes the car there goes
the car well they just they had to film
that last
cars didn't weren't worth much money
back then anyway that's true yeah uh
so so the car goes into the water and
then you know all the cops come
obviously
and they're like dragging the lake
or river whatever it is in you know the
most inefficient way possible
and uh basically they're like oh the
current's too strong we're never gonna
find that car
now i didn't catch this um
but i guess somebody says that it's like
three hours later and they still haven't
found the car
and then all of a sudden mary played by
candice hilagos
comes climbing out of the river
and you know and she seems fine but she
doesn't really remember
like what happened so they're just kind
of like how the [ __ ]
you know no one says this but you
basically you're like how the [ __ ] did
she stay under there like all that time
and still be alive
so they put a blanket around and they're
like holy crap whatever and so then they
cut to the next scene
yeah and she's uh playing this enormous
pipe organ yeah now jenny forgot to
mention a few things
what did i forget to mention the dudes
driving the car were [ __ ]
hilarious looking the one dude had a hat
that was [ __ ]
bizarre yeah and on rifftrax they had a
great time
they had a great time making fun yeah
and it's hard to tell how old they are i
think they were
in their 20s but everybody looked older
but they all looked kind of old the way
they dressed
even 20 year olds looked like 45 year
olds he looked like cooking what's his
name abbott
from evan costello he did a bit kind of
like no no he looked like a
cow's still a little short fat guy when
he wasn't either
oh
but he wasn't fat he just looked like
that and uh he was husky
yeah it was funny the girls were cute in
the car
probably late teens early 20s but
there's something about that hair it
made them look like old ladies even when
they were young it's funny i guess
because we associate that with old lady
hair
i think that's probably what it is
because i was actually surprised to find
out that uh
that the actress that played mary was
only 20. yeah and she looked like the
oldest one out
in this and she did she looked like she
didn't look like an old woman but she
looked like she was like she's about 30.
she looked like she was in her 30s
yeah that's what i said hair though it i
think that's definitely what it is now
she is cute she looks just
reminded me of that woman who played the
chick out of [ __ ]
natasha henson yeah species she looks
like that she her face does look a bit
like yeah
she's got great bone structure yeah real
thin and so she you know
and the other ones were cute too that
they they went off into the drink and
died
you don't see them anymore yeah but uh
just kind of funny to see and they had
it all colorized the colorized version
i thought the color was convincing it
looked like it was shot in color
um i think it did a pretty good job jane
didn't like it but
well i don't like it because just
because the black and white
cinematography was so pretty
was like you know i thought the black
and white cinematography looks
much much easier i didn't have a any
kind of conceived notion about it to me
the color because i've never seen it to
me the color looked good and it
did well they did do a good job on the
colorization it does look real
but i just i thought it was interesting
to see all that 50s and 60s stuff in
color
and one of the things i noticed is like
how bad the paint jobs were on cars back
then i remembered those
those cars were jalopy's when i was a
little kid but i remembered them
man the paint was shitty really [ __ ] oh
yeah everything was kind of [ __ ]
everything was kind of
nobody knew any better they didn't have
good quality stuff the technology wasn't
there yet
yeah and the interiors and everything so
if you're if you were around california
and or in the south
in the 70s a lot of this stuff you know
you haven't seen it in a long time
like i remember when i remember [ __ ]
wallpaper that looked like that i'm glad
that's gone that kind of [ __ ] you know
porcelain bathrooms and [ __ ] yeah all
the tiles and everything i'm glad all
that shit's gone
yeah like i said everything's kind of
crazy it looks all crappy yeah so
so yeah so she uh supposedly recovers
from this accident doesn't seem all that
put out about it and by the way her two
friends are dead
um you know we're presuming because they
never did find the car
so she immediately is like she's playing
this big pipe organ like i said uh this
is not the movie to watch
if you don't like pipe organ music
because man there's a lot of
things it's all in but like i said it
goes in with the whole carnival uh
theme the dude that did the uh all the
score is named jean moore by the way
and i think they actually released uh
this whole album of this because that
the
music is actually kind of creepy but so
she's playing that and it turns out that
that's her job she's like
she's an organist and um you know she
went to college for and everything
i don't know she really knew how to play
the organ if they were just pretending i
don't know
but um so she basically says to the guy
that she's working for yeah i got a job
as a church organist out in utah so i'm
gonna leave right away
and then they're building up stuff like
the you know they keep asking her
questions like well are you gonna stop
and see your family and she's like no no
i don't have time to do that whatever
it's just
and then like the guys are talking about
like wow she seemed to like get over her
being like [ __ ]
pulled out of the [ __ ] river after
three hours underwater like she seems to
be recovering from that pretty well but
they think it's like kind of weird
yeah so what now here's another thing
jenny's not mentioning
if this is the phase of the movie where
you're getting where you're getting to
see
all the old white guys that run the show
in this [ __ ] movie these dudes man
looking at them and just the way they
are kind of [ __ ] reminds me of
[ __ ]
meeting your grandparents when they were
a little bit young these are the people
that your grandparents looked up to they
were just
like they were from another [ __ ]
universe jumpy weirdos the rear
what's that don't be weirdos yeah
kind of weird and super straight lace
real straight lace
yeah and real um like uh
early 60s thai wearing [ __ ]
with their hair
greased back and slicked back and gray
and a little bit dumpy and overweight
and
um kind of moral authority type guys i
think that'd be a good way everything is
some kind of a moral authority
authoritative lesson
you know i mean they're helping guiding
you through reality you know what i mean
they're trying to explain to you
they're mansplaining oh they're [ __ ]
man's playing mansplaining to the
and then and it's and it's just like
you'll get two of them on screen
and they will mansplain to each other so
you could overhear it in a movie
so you can understand an entire concept
that they're trying to teach it's it's a
trip movie if you look at it that way
you're talking about it is weird
well yeah it is weird yeah it's a lesson
teaching [ __ ]
but i'm not sure what the lesson was
well i don't even know if that was
intended so much it's just the way they
delivered
dialogue well it's exposition yeah
yeah it's just like an exposition where
you know we're we're
being led to think that you know you
would think that she would be acting
differently because of like a traumatic
i mean if you went off a [ __ ] bridge
into a car and even if you lived but
your two best friends presumably
were in the car and they died and it was
only like a few days ago
yeah you'd think you'd be more like but
she's just kind of like whatevs yeah but
in a modern movie they never would have
mentioned that they just would have kept
on going it'd be on you
as the viewer well yeah but i kind of
what the hell yeah in the 50s they just
had to tell you how to think they didn't
really trust people to figure [ __ ] out
on their own
and to tell you how to so everything had
to be
kind of explaining to you and explaining
to you how you should be feeling about
this
explaining to you how you because what
they're trying to tell you what is
normal
yeah and it's not normal so there were
you should feel like that so that was
just kind of a weird
50s whereas like you said if they made
it nowadays they wouldn't
they wouldn't have that conversation
they wouldn't because you know and
movies nowadays do have exposition
sometimes but if you have exposition in
a movie nowadays everyone's going to
jump on your [ __ ] about it because it's
like we don't
tell you well you don't really need that
like people are sophisticated enough to
be like okay i got it like i didn't you
don't
have to like tell me you don't explain
like your plot to me
um you know what i mean but back then i
guess they felt like they had to
i think i think it was two things one it
was written for the lowest common
denominator two they were trying to fill
the movie out
well yeah because and this movie is like
pretty short too it's only like 84
minutes i want to say there's some cuts
that are shorter like that are 79
minutes i think it's about 84 minutes is
like the
the director's cut like the way it was
supposed to be seen
so she ends up driving to utah and on
the way to utah she starts seeing
well you know what will become kind of
familiar later on like throughout the
movie is that she starts seeing this
dude like a ghoul looking dude
like visions of him she sees them like
in the car window and she sees them and
then
like i said that's the director her
carvey uh playing that part
you know just wearing two hats so it's
like saving some money
you know like you do and so she gets to
utah she gets a job as a church organist
and it seems very um upsetting to people
that she's really kind of i mean
nowadays it wouldn't be that big a deal
but it's like she seems almost
she didn't say she's an atheist but
she's just kind of like oh i just work
at a church and play the organ you know
i play organ
for money and it's like so church is
just like any other job it's just like
any other business
which like i said is not controversial
to say nowadays but in 1962 everyone was
like flipping the [ __ ] out about it
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so
you're being
as i said you're being led to believe
that there's something
the matter with her like fundamentally
the matter with her
uh since the accident right so as it
goes on
she starts having not only seeing
because she gets like a
room in a boarding house with like the
weirdest landlady ever
yeah i love that the la i love her
character though i love that landlady
she's like so [ __ ] funny
i love that she's so obsessed with
telling the girl
you can take all the baths you want like
i'm not
one to get upset but she says like two
or three times and it's just like so so
funny that that's like the thing that
she's like latching onto and i'm like
this work is this
woman a pervert or what and speaking of
speaking of perverts
there is another border in the house
like this dude i think his name is john
and he lives across the hall from her
and this dude
is like a total [ __ ] skis yeah
you know what i mean i mean you have it
has to be seen to be believed yeah
like what a skis this dude is yeah and
i'm not sure if he was supposed to be
that skeezy
in the 60s that he might have been kind
of normal for the 60s it's hard to say
or they i think he i think he was
supposed to he was supposed to be a skis
though was he
okay i would maybe be kind of like a
futuristic
kind of a guy who was cool with [ __ ]
it's hard to t it's hard to say because
i'm pretty sure he was supposed to be
the people who wrote this kind of stuff
what they thought was normal and what
they thought was
cool were was a lot different and i mean
i mean i'm pretty sure back then he was
supposed to be a skis just because of
the way she was reacting to him and
stuff but i think like from today's
standards i think he'd
be like you restraining order that'd be
like just a restraining order right
there it's like please get the [ __ ]
because he won't yeah but they did a lot
of stuff back then
but i mean the thing about it though is
like he'll come to the door like he just
comes in
like he's not invited in or nothing like
he won't leave
and it's just like he's just constantly
hovering over he's like way too close
and [ __ ] like that
and he's like following her and [ __ ]
it's like it's creepy as hell
and he's just like a total total he's
just and i was just
he brings like [ __ ] over to her house
like uninvited it's like he's going yeah
well
today that'd be totally unacceptable
that'd be like set on 10.
but back in the 60s that may have not
have been like on a 10
setting i kind of feel like maybe back
then it was a six more like a six
right yeah because i think he was
supposed to be a creep
but but didn't it comes off even worse
now but now it comes off even worse than
it would have back then although even
back then i'm pretty sure that he was
used to come across
but i think back then he was like maybe
half as bad as you would see it now yeah
nowadays like i said you'd be like
spraying
with me because they did they believe
like i said some of their their value
system is real different
yeah totally creepy yeah i mean and in
some ways like i said because i think
one of the things
her interactions with him i think are
supposed to show
again yes he's supposed to be a creep
but also they're trying to highlight
her being abnormal because she doesn't
want a relationship
yeah it's which is weird because you
think to make that
more clear i think they should have made
the dude like a normal nice dude
by making him like this creepy skis it
almost kind of seems like oh well she
doesn't want a relationship with this
guy what the [ __ ] is the matter with her
i'm like maybe she just doesn't like
that dude yeah well i think he's like a
[ __ ] sleazebag i was watching that
too but
i think we were supposed to see be
seeing it from from the
from the viewpoint of a young person in
the 60s and that was the very beginning
of kind of like the
sexual revolution was just starting yeah
and they had uh like uh what do you call
them guys um
guys are listening to all the jazz the
beatniks and [ __ ] those guys had been
around for a long time
i think what we were supposed to see is
kind of like the equivalent of
a punk rock dude who just met some goth
chick they were [ __ ] bored
you know what i mean boarding in this
house
you know what i mean yeah and that
you're you're like a normie in the
movies theater
watching a punk rock guy and a [ __ ]
goth girl that's what i think it was
supposed to be
but it didn't translate to modern
culture yeah i think it was
i mean she straight up says later on
uh to a doctor that she just kind of
stumbles across which i'll get to in a
minute
that she is doesn't have any interest at
all
in relationships not romantic
relationships or friendships or anything
she basically just wants to be alone but
like i said they're trying to highlight
her
being weird being weird or being like
her whole thing
she even says later on in the movie she
even says i don't belong in this world
which like i said it turns out to be
very literal yeah well
now that fits in right in from with the
60s and the late 50s kind of thinking
a woman's job back then was to be in a
relationship
that was her job and if you didn't want
one you know there was something wrong
with you
yeah but i think they're just kind of
showing it i think i think there was a
lot of people that felt that way
yeah so they were trying like i said
you're supposed to be a young person in
the theater
i think seeing connor like the version
of a goth girl and a punk rock
dude hooking up in a in a boarding room
but it doesn't come across that way to
us because it's just
the styles they're so kind of old people
and fuddy-duddy from our point of view
yeah you know what i mean that's not
translating the cultural
equivalence is hard for us to see i
think that's what it was though
they were supposed to be cool kids
yeah i think although like i said she
comes across as much older than a 20
year old she comes across much older
than he does
even though they're probably the same
age or actually he might be a little he
might be a little bit older but um he
comes across
i mean he he is supposed to be like i
said kind of a creep because he's
clearly an alcoholic they're not trying
to like sugarcoat that at all well it's
like a pump rocker though yeah he's like
drinking in the morning and [ __ ] like
that so like i said he's not supposed to
be a good guy like she's supposed to
like fall over
like over himself well i don't think
they were totally condemning him either
i think they were trying no i don't even
know i don't think they were either like
i said i think they were supposed to be
cool people
yeah it's just that we're not seeing it
through that through their eyes yeah i
think that's what was intended
oh man they're cool at hip they but
they're 20 right they're in there maybe
we're talk going on a little too long
about it yeah we're 20.
i'm just trying to get into the mindset
of who wrote this they're 20.
well just a decade before you had guys
who were 17 and 18 flying down bombers
and [ __ ] burning japan down
those were young adults
in that era they weren't really kids
yeah but they were considered to be i
think they're supposed to be cool we
were supposed to think that they're cool
i think yeah i don't you know i don't
know what's because i
think so i wasn't alive back then and
now you know i don't know but uh so
anyway so
so she's in this and there's all this
weird [ __ ] going on and then
significantly like i said she keeps
seeing this
ghoul dude like turning up she sees him
outside the window she sees him like
down in the lobby of like the
it's not the lobby but it's like you
know the living room of the boarding
house she's staying at
and she's like kind of freaking out
about it and nobody else seems to see
him
then she starts having these kind of
fugue states i guess you would call him
where it's like she's
like she's at a department store like
shopping for clothes and everything's
normal
like she's trying on dresses and whatnot
and then all of a sudden
there's like this kind of weird like
wavy kind of [ __ ] happening
and then she goes back out and suddenly
it seems like no one can see her
or hear her anymore so she's just kind
of like talking to people and they're
just ignoring her and like nobody can
see her
and it's like kind of wigging her out
and like that happens
um a couple of times something i never
noticed before and then i saw like an
analysis of this that someone was
talking about they said that the couple
times that that happens where she goes
into these weird fugue states where no
one can see or hear her
um even though she's talking and it's
weird because it's like the only noise
you can hear
like as noises she makes like her
footsteps or whatever
but what the thing that brings her out
of this fugue and i think it's
both times or two or three times that
she has one of these
is bird singing and i said i wonder was
that intentional because i thought that
like some kind of birds are like
what are they called like a psycho pomp
right it's like they transfer
souls like from the living to the dead
so maybe they were trying to like imply
that she was like in between
um which i mean you know it's or maybe
that was just the only sound effect they
had or maybe they did think about it i
don't really know
but so she has like these weird fugues
and starts wigging out and during one of
these fugues she happens to run into a
doctor he's not a psychiatrist he's just
like some kind of regular doctor
and he's like we'll come back to my
office i'll help you out and so she's
like talking to him
and she explains all this [ __ ] that
happens and he's basically saying you
know
he doesn't say this but it's like this
is the implication well you're just a
woman and you're hysterical whatever
um you know it's this dude doesn't
really exist you said nobody else saw
him it's like maybe
maybe you're having like sometimes
survivors guilt because your friends
died in the accident and you didn't and
it's like wigging you out and you're not
really
um you know you're not really dealing
with your uh
your trauma or anything you've just
decided to like shut off he doesn't use
those words but that's kind of what he's
uh saying that's what they would say in
like modern parlance
because she like i said she tells the
guy i don't feel like i belong here i
feel like um
you know i'm not interested in other
people i'm not interested
in religion or anything like that so
what they're trying to say and i think
they even say this a couple times
outright
is that she is now soulless
um i think that even when she's playing
the organ at the church she ends up
getting fired from the church because
she spaces out when she's playing the
hymns or whatever and starts playing
some more like demonic sound and [ __ ]
um which you know it's like kind of
creepy carnival kind of music and then
like the priest
the priest or preacher or whatever like
gets all [ __ ] flipped out i was like
what's that
sacrilegious [ __ ] you're playing it's
like get the [ __ ] out of here you
heathen
um so so it kind of goes like that so i
think the implication
is that she doesn't have a soul anymore
i don't think
because spoiler alert when you get to
the end there's this whole thing where
she goes
she finally goes like is drawn back to
this carnival which she's kind
of kept coming back to this abandoned
carnival because she's like obsessed
with it
and she goes there and then there's all
these ghouls and they're all like
dancing around and like the main goal is
like dancing with a ghoul that looks
like her
and then she runs away from them at the
end and falls down in the sand
and then like they show all these cops
that would be like well her car is
parked here but then like where she fell
down in the sand like there's no
body and there's no like footprints
leaving from it and so they can't figure
out where she went
and then they go back to kansas from the
beginning and then they show that
they're dredging
the car from the very beginning of the
movie
and she's still in there so she's been
so you can say yes she's been dead the
whole time but the thing
about it is that i don't think it's as
simple you know it's it's not like a
sixth sense type of thing like at night
shyamalan like rip this off i don't
think she's necessarily a ghost
i think it's either she's some kind of
like weird revenant like i said she's
walking around like just her
like some version of her body is walking
around but it doesn't have the soul in
it because it's back in the car
or she was dying under there the whole
time and this whole and then the whole
movie was like
um a weird like dream that she was
having
yeah of of you know of these ghouls like
coming to get her
to come and get her soul you know the
narrative of the movie was unclear
i mean well it's ambiguous and i think
that was on purpose
i knew what they were talking about as
soon as she as soon as
she you see her on the bank after the
damn car
went into the water she was dry well no
she no she wasn't she was
she was wet okay she was wet and muddy
okay i thought she was dressed
anyway you just like uh why would only
she survive i knew that they were gonna
say she was some kind of ghost or
something
yeah i mean i don't think like i said i
don't think she was dry at first though
no
she wasn't exactly i don't think she was
exactly a ghost because
she interacted with other people it was
just sometimes
but sometimes they couldn't see her yeah
so it's almost kind of more like
she was in the car the whole time and
that was like a projection
and that was almost so that was almost
kind of like a dream of
a hallucination of like the ghouls or
like to come in like fighting over her
soul
or something like that so maybe like the
whole thing in utah was just like all in
her head it was just like a dream of
like dying
which like i said is that's a thing
that's been done
in stories that's [ __ ] that would make
the most sense well that's going back to
[ __ ] uh
ambrose beers uh an occurrence at owl
creek bridge which when did that come
out 1832 something like that like that
short story where it was like a dude
being hung and he
he it seemed like he escaped and went
through all these adventures and blah
blah blah but then it turned out that he
was just that was
you know a projection in his head like
he actually did die so i kind of
i kind of feel like that's where they
were going that would make the most
sense
because if she's not a ghost because
people can see her and interact and
touch her
and things like that most of the time
i've been back in a car dying i think
she was back in the car dying and it was
just like a projection which like i said
in a way kind of makes it better because
then that's
it's this weird surreal like dream that
she's having while her life is being
right because i guess it doesn't make
any sense to you any other way
yeah because if she was a ghost like i
said right because the thing about this
because the thing about the sixth sense
which we were talking about before is
his yes
spoiler bruce willis was dead the whole
time but
the only person that interacted with
bruce willis was the kid who could see
dead people nobody else interacted with
him or touched him or anything
which you don't really notice the first
time that you watch it if you don't know
what the
what the thing is but in this one people
absolutely do touch her and interact
with her
and most of the time other than the few
fugues that she has
you know people can see her and hear her
and she's interacting with people normal
so i don't think that she's supposed to
be a ghost
yeah so i guess that's why it might be
considered you know some people consider
this an important movie which i guess
i guess maybe it does it would seem that
way i didn't really
think there was much to it i mean like i
said the movie's kind of dated it's all
atmosphere pretty much
and like i said it looks way better than
black i'm pretty sure
pretty sure there's a bunch of social
commentary that we're not picking up
because we're just we're just you know
not old enough
well i mean all the things that they say
about her that make her weird are
trying to they're trying to make her
seem like she's soulless
as in she doesn't care about the church
she's just playing at the church because
for money like she doesn't give a [ __ ]
about that um
she's not interested in a relationship
like i think the the creepy dude even
asks her are you afraid of men and she
says no
but it's just like i think that maybe
would have that angle would have played
better if that dude wasn't such a creep
because it's like any woman in their
right mind would not any want anything
to do with that [ __ ] rapey
[ __ ]
so it's like if the dude had just been
like normal um
that might have played a lot better if
she was like freaked out by that dude
you know who was like a perfectly yeah i
don't know man you know what i mean i
kind of i kind of have a sneaking
suspicion that
we were supposed to think that that guy
was cool i don't see i don't know i
don't i don't think so i don't think
it's hard to tell because like you said
it's hard to put yourself
okay look i mean he even says there's a
point like he takes her out on a date
right because he won't take no for an
answer
and to be fair she is kind of like
because she's scared because she doesn't
really know what's going on so sometimes
she's just like hey [ __ ] off and then
sometimes she's like no i don't want to
be alone so she's giving him some mixed
signals too i will give give her that
give him that but um you know because
she doesn't really know what's going on
and she's freaking out also because she
thinks she's losing her marbles right
so you know but he when he takes her out
on the date
and then he just like says horrible [ __ ]
to like whoa you don't like to drink
either
you know he's like picking on her but
then he sees like a friend of his
and he says to the friend that um
you know one he lies about who he is
normal
kind of pig you usually bring in here
it's all kinds of cool [ __ ] yeah well
and he says to that guy he's like i
don't want her it's like you know she's
kind of more of a classy chick i don't
want her knowing that i
you know knowing that i know dudes like
you so you're meant to
and like i said they they don't make a
secret of the fact that he's a drunk
either
so i don't think he's supposed to be
like the
ideal man um you know what i mean
and and i know that like back then men
could get away with being a lot more
pushy
than nowadays like like i said nowadays
you get pepper spray in your face
but um but back then they could get but
i don't think that he was supposed to be
like a normal dude i think he was
supposed to be like kind of a creep
but maybe maybe not as much of a creep
as nowadays you know what i'm saying
but honestly if i know that they were
just trying to make it seem like she
didn't have a soul like i said she
wasn't interested in friends she wasn't
interested in seeing her family which uh
you know one of the
people mentioned when she was going on
the trip you know she wasn't interested
in church she wasn't interested in
anything like that
she didn't care that her friends were
dead you know that kind of [ __ ]
so there's a bunch of stuff in there
that generally generationally we're
missing
i mean well that's true well from that
movie i can watch a
well-written movie like rebel without a
cause i don't understand half that damn
movie
well that's what i'm saying pretty much
every movie from that era well it's just
i mean and that's going to happen
there's nothing wrong with that because
you didn't grow up during that time
periods there's obviously going to be
some [ __ ] that you
you know some context that you're
missing out on
but that's the context and it's also
like the situation
the situation that you were brought up
in at that time
their consciousnesses were very
different i mean [ __ ] you know
characters are doing and reacting in
ways you know like [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] uh he he's
the dude from rebel without cause what's
his name [ __ ] james dean's
ovary overact overreacting to things in
weird ways and like dude man shut the
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] i mean he's like
whiny and and i don't know what he's
upset about because
i wasn't brought up in that era so you
know what i mean [ __ ]
you know he's got problems that that
don't didn't exist in my time
yeah well the thing about it too and i
think we've talked about this before
is that you didn't really see a lot of
movies about
teenage rebellion because it was kind of
like a new thing yeah you know what i
mean so it was like oh here's this new
youth thing that we're
doing in a movie yeah it's hard to
understand what he was upset about
because they didn't grow up in that in
the environment well again but evidently
kids of that era loved that movie and
could really relate to what he was
complaining yeah so obviously they
struck a nerve yeah you know they they
love that movie it's just we didn't
grow up he knew exactly what he was
talking about and we and
but we can watch it and go what's he
talking about so the context the context
isn't there
yeah which you know right and like i
said even
even [ __ ] that came out when i was a kid
like in the 70s
even those movies like even though i
understand the context more because i
was actually there and i kind of knew
what was going on
even now sometimes i'll watch movies
from the 70s and be like wait what
you know what i mean so it's just so you
know
there's really no way to get around that
because
i mean unless you really really like
study
but i don't think unless you grew up in
that time period you're not going to be
able to like really
like relate some of the same way that
somebody that age would
some of the stuff from the 1930s those
just instantly understandable because it
never really gets too deep
it's all just you know i mean kind of on
the surface yeah which is strange i've
seen some movies
you understand everything yeah like from
way long
way longer ago that are more which yeah
that's very odd well because i guess
because history is more like cyclical
it's kind of like a cycle like stuff
that from the 50s i'm just kind of like
what
but it's like you know older stuff like
from the 20s and 30s i'm way more into
that because
you know i like a lot of movies from
like the 20s and stuff well they're
um because there wasn't as much
ambiguity to anything either
well and culturally it wasn't as uptight
yeah they weren't
fifties i think that's what it was so it
was it's a lot more similar to
uh to [ __ ] nowadays watch the black cat
man and he's talking about necrophilia
and [ __ ]
enslaving people's [ __ ] daughters all
that free
that pre-haze code [ __ ] yeah it's like
[ __ ] satanism
you can make one of those movies now and
people be like yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] bellagosi tortures boris karloff
to death
with a [ __ ] pliers damn
yeah see they're a hardcore back then
like i said i kind of feel like the 50s
was you know it was just so they were so
inhibited you couldn't understand what
they were talking about
yeah that a lot of the stuff and you
know a lot of the social like and gender
roles and stuff like that were just so
rigid that it was just kind of like i
don't really get it anymore
so you know but i mean i can see where
they were coming from but i didn't grow
up during that era and it's just like
weird to me
but so yeah so i don't know we're just
so i can't believe we spent so much time
like
on this day well no on that one creepy
character
well it is kind of that is an anomalous
feature of this movie i've just got to
say i mean i watch this movie to the
for me the mo the movie
most of the movie i didn't really think
but that particular character
what got me was i wasn't sure how i was
supposed
to feel about the guy it was ambiguous a
lot about this movie is ambiguous like i
said but that's in a way i think that's
why a lot of people dug it because it
was just kind of like this strange
right like one-off kind of i kind of got
the feeling that they
that you were supposed to kind of think
that that dude was futuristic and ahead
of his time
that's what i think that they were
trying what they were trying to get at
i don't know because maybe from the
point of the 60s maybe he was
maybe somebody that grew up during that
era would be able to like
oh yeah he's cool he's cool he's i'm
just like on his mind
holy crap what a [ __ ] yeah he's
saying what's on his mind
he's treating a woman the way she should
be treated that's right
she's looking at it from a different
viewpoint i'm going like i think
some dudes well i mean you might be
right to an extent but like i said i
i don't think he was supposed to be a
good guy because they did have some
traits
yeah that were about him that were not
good like i said his alcoholism because
he was like drinking in the morning like
just
yeah but it might have been justified
well we're all drinking because this
[ __ ]
sucks because you can't be like this you
can't tell a woman what you really think
you know it's like that you know
keep that [ __ ] in line that's right you
paid for that beer
make a drink so it's so
put some roofies in there right right
right right
why are you roofing her already damn
that's it from the past
so i think i think jay's looking at from
a female point of view but i'm looking
at it from a male point of view
that may have been a role model see
god i hope not it might have been that's
why i was looking well no i'm not i'm
not arguing
yeah it might have been like i said i'm
not a dude and i'm not the dude that
made this movie either so it's kind of
like that might have been a men's rights
[ __ ]
role model i think it's what that was
they're holding him down society's
holding him down
and now this woman's holding him down
damn he paid for the beer put out
i think it's what they're talking about
always keeping their legs closed like i
said it's hard to tell because there was
a lot of that
[ __ ] going on in the 50s so yeah i'm
just saying that it's like
i i understand why that character was in
there but
i don't know what you're supposed to
think well no i mean i don't know him
being that
like that i think it would have worked
better if he was more like straight
laced because then it would have seemed
weirder that she was refusing him you
know what i'm saying
that's all couple years later dudes like
that were replaced wally's age of
aquarius age oh here here's some pot now
open your legs
it was that's it was basically well that
worked much better that worked a lot
better
but i think it was that same kind of
dude free drugs okay yeah
all right yeah all right so anyway
this has been our yeah our our 50s
dissertation this isn't early 60s but
it's still kind of simple yeah the very
fifties
dissertation about the carnival yeah
like i said this movie is
free it's everywhere if you want to see
it like super beautiful if you're like
really into you know film and everything
i would recommend the criterion
collection uh version because i've heard
that it looks
gorgeous but if you just want to like
watch it and
laugh then you can watch the riftrax
versions of which there
are two uh rifftrax versions live
and regular and then there's one i think
with just mike
and uh they're all on 2b for free if you
want to watch those and the original
version is also on 2b for free and it's
also on
shutter so uh go watch it you know
why not like you have anything better to
do anyway
so that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we'll be
back for the next one bye
you